two weeks to go and the race has begun
in Malaysia's election candidates and
their supporters throng nomination
centers to contest some of 222
parliamentary seats that are up for
grabs there are six million new eligible
voters this year that's a result of
automatic voter registration and because
the voting age has been lowered from 21
to 18 years a million are under the age
of 20. it is a step forward to really
empowering the youth and being able to
involve them within the larger sphere of
decision making and nation building in
Malaysia while on the other hand I
realized that because of the year's
generation of political apathy there's a
lot of foundation that needs to be built
first if we truly want to exercise that
right to vote effectively Muhammad
imamul arifin is a university student
who's eligible to vote for the first
time
so please don't forget to vote he's
filming a social media video to
encourage fellow students to vote we are
very young in Malaysia as a democracy
and as an individual as a Malaysian
citizen
your voice your vote who has the power
in making the most minute of changes and
making the country move forward analysts
say first-time voters could be a
potential wildcard if they turn out to
vote at all there's also a chance that
this this group of individuals will not
vote for the incumbent because there was
no reason for them previously to go out
and vote so if there's an incentive for
them to go out and vote it could be to
want to change things they might find
something new or find something
different a recent survey suggests a
third of Voters are undecided or
indifferent there will be intense
competition for these votes
Malaysia has been rocked by political
instability three prime ministers in the
last four years
baristan National a coalition that has
dominated politics is hoping to secure
enough seats to form the next government
on its own the main opposition blocked
pakatan harapan is hoping for a surprise
win an opinion poll is already
predicting no one party is likely to win
a simple majority